einen schönen guten tag und willkommen
zu zdf heute live es ist angerichtet
kann man sagen wenn das wort klassiker
auf einer paarung im weltfußball
zutrifft dann mit sicherheit auf die
england gegen deutschland das ganze dann
am besten auch noch im wembley stadion
ein ort mit einer einzigartigen historie
mit großen siegen für die deutschen aber
natürlich auch einer ganz besonders
schmerzlichen niederlage heute das
neuauflage geschehen sozusagen die
neuauflage das achtelfinale also bei der
europameisterschaft und darüber wollen
wir sprechen zum einen natürlich mit
euch eure fragen und kommentare wie
immer gerne hat uns zum beispiel auch
die frage die ich gleich schon mal an
euch stellen kann wo ihr heute abend
fußball schaut also gerne mehr dazu mit
euch sprechen aber auch eben mit béla
réthy und mit andreas stamm
andreas ist unser korrespondent in
england und wähler natürlich eine
fußballreporter legende des zdf hat
selbst einige persönliche erfahrungen
gesammelt mit diesem klassiker und an
dieser stelle herzlich willkommen an
euch beide schön dass ihr dabei sah
zunächst die frage an den fußball
reporter an béla was verbindest du dann
auf den punkt gebracht mit dieser
begegnung
das ist so wie ich persönlich eine ganze
emotionale stütze gewesen ich habe ja
dort man an der erste signale
kommentiert 1996 dann habe ich gott das
champions-league-finale kommentiert 2013
bayern und dortmund in großartige
spieler und ich war dabei
im alten wembley-stadion bevor es
abgerissen worden ist im jahre 2000 als
didi hamann dort das letzte tor schoss
für die deutsche nationalmannschaft
bevor das stadion abgerissen worden ist
aber es war nicht der grund des abrisses
und das war ohnehin schon vorgesehen
also einige großartige geschichte
nämlich mit diesem ort wie diesem film
bbc kathedrale des fußballs verbinden
die werden wir gleich auch noch mal
streifen also diese historie andreas du
bist vor dem stadion
und wenn ich dich so sehe dann habe ich
den eindruck du musst es schon die eine
oder andere champagner-dusche der
engländer über dich erklären lassen
sind die eindrücke die du bislang
sammeln konnte die champagner wird hier
nicht getrunken hier wird natürlich
standesgemäß bier getrunken keine frage
rein ist es bombenstimmung überhaupt
überhaupt keine frage
ich meine wir haben corona pandemie ich
will das jetzt gar nicht jetzt hier mit
anfangen aber hier die leute haben
einfach in unglaublichem bock an fest zu
feiern und fußball fest zu feiern und
dieses spiel elektrisiert die englischen
fußballfans wie kein anderes das ist
eben wembley 66 das wembley 96 drehung
für schmerzhafte niederlagen
elfmeterschießen gary lineker der
berühmteste fußball spruch vielleicht
aller zeiten zumindest hier auf der
insel 22 ein einfaches spiel 90 minuten
am ende gewinnen die deutschen
also das ist tolle stimmung hier ob man
das mitten in der pandemie machen muss
das kann man sicherlich diskutieren aber
die stimmung ist wirklich großartig man
echt viele lustige gespräche geführt und
die leute haben einfach lust auf diesen
klassiker andreas dass wenn wir gleich
noch vertiefen auch natürlich die
kritischen aspekte dieser begegnungen
sprechen aber zunächst mit bela und
bevor wir dazu kommen bringt uns lars
ruthemann nochmal auf den aktuellen
stand der dinge kurz vor der begegnung
da sollte eigentlich jetzt der beitrag
von herrn gutem einkommen ich frage
gerade noch mal eben die regie ob er
vorliegt oder ob wir mit bela direkt
weiter machen
aha also es kann sich nur um wenige
sekunden handeln wir wollen ja um das
gespräch schon mal ein bisschen
sozusagen vorzubereiten euch alle auf
den aktuellen stand bringen wie sieht's
aus im kader der deutschen aber auch bei
den engländern und jetzt der beitrag von
lars ruthemann
okay wir haben es zweimal versucht es
hat leider nicht geklappt
wir machen weiter mit unserem fachmann
mit béla réthy also bilder es ist so der
beitrag hörte damit auf dass es im
prinzip schon zwei gewinner gibt es bei
dieser geschichte denn es wurde sich da
einig darüber dass beide mannschaften
sozusagen den kniefall machen das ist
eine geste gegen rassismus und für
respekt untereinander beide werden auch
die regenbogen binde tragen also viel
versöhnliche töne im prinzip schon im
vorfeld auf der anderen seite muss man
sagen klar es wird nur einen gewinner
geben nur eine mannschaft kommt dann
auch tatsächlich weiter wenn du jetzt
die leistungen beider mannschaften in
diesem turnier bislang bewährt ist wer
hat da für dich die nase vorne und
worauf wird es ankommen
insgesamt würde ich schon sagen dass wir
deutsche mannschaft eine höhere
gesamtqualität hat die hat also nicht so
stark begründung gegen frankreich sehr
gut gespielt gegen portugal dann wieder
ein schwächeres spiel gegen ungarn also
die ist jetzt wieder mal ein gutes spiel
daran dass im champions- league-sieger
darin das sind weltmeister darin die
gesamte das gesamtgefüge der deutschen
mannschaft ist eigentlich das bessere
es müssen endlich mal abrufen ich bin
insgesamt nicht zufrieden mit der
offensive der löw-elf aber auch die der
engländer ist auch eher mäßig das war
also ich hatte von england zieht viel
mehr erwartet ich war neben belgien für
mich eure favoriten für dieses turnier
weil die mannschaft die hat 2018 in
russland schon sehr gute ansätze gezeigt
dass die drei jahre reifen mehr
zugetraut dass er sehr unansehnlich
fußball bisher den den england gezeigt
hat für mich ist trotzdem ist nach da
jetzt eine auswärtsmannschaft sind in
der tat einen nachteil bei mit
zuschauern auf der englischen seite wo
die deutschen dürfen ja nicht einreißen
die deutsche mannschaft insgesamt von
ihrem potenzial her heute favorisiert
auf und es sind wird aber ich glaube
deutschland weiter über den zuschauer
aspekt sprechen dann nachher noch mit
andreas stammen aber du hast es
angesprochen die performance bislang
beider mannschaften im turnier eher
mäßig der engländer immerhin sieben
punkte aber auch knappe siege zweimal 1
0 1 0 0
und die deutschen mit vier punkten auf
platz zwei allerdings auch in der sehr
schweren gruppe kommen wir noch einmal
ganz kurz bevor wir über die aktualität
weitersprechen auf die vergangen
zurück also es ist eben ein klassiker
weil es eben schon so viele bedeutende
spiele der beiden gegeben hat bei großen
turnieren da haben wir nochmal ein paar
highlights rausgesucht unter anderem
natürlich ja die mutter sozusagen aller
dramen 1966 das em bzw wm finale war es
ja damals gucken wir gerade vielleicht
noch mal drauf wenn wir die bilder
vorliegen haben
das ist der berühmte schuss von geoff
erst in der verlängerung genau
unterkante latte und dann auf die linie
spätere untersuchungen haben dann
ergeben dass er nicht drin war aber das
tor hat gezählt war zum 3 zu 2 später
dann 4 zu 2
das bitter für deutschland auf der
anderen seite hier beim bled 72 das tor
von uli hoeneß das endete 3 1 war das em
viertelfinale deutschland später dann
mit dem titel und natürlich 96 der
fehlschuss von southgate im halbfinale
bei der em und dann andreas müller
wuchtig in die maschen genau und das war
dann das ticket fürs finale
ja und das finale hast du dann auch eben
kommentiert béla darüber hattest du
gerade schon gesprochen also das waren
tolle szenen bis auf 66 eigentlich auch
immer mit gutem ausgang für die
deutschen warum bilder liegen uns die
engländer offenbar so jetzt zum beispiel
im vergleich zu finden ich zeitig je
nach wunsch fast immer schief gegangen
ist ich weiß auch nicht das ist halt so
eine alte gewachsene traditionen
rivalität da schaukelt sich hoch mit
beleidigung juni in der boulevardpresse
mit allen drohen dran das ist so viele
emotionen drin und die deutschen hat
offenbar ihre emotionen nur besser unter
kontrolle wieder 66 war die einzige
ausnahme wenn es damals schon dem video
dem video es ist
referee gegeben hätte dann wäre das
möglicherweise auch noch anders
ausgegangen
das war ja noch eine ganz andere zeit
hab so erlebt also in südamerika da habe
ich gelebt habe es im radio gehört und
brauchbare namen wie hier kowski oder
beckenbauer oder wie die spieler alle
hießen und/oder der hoch geschätzte
kollege der der damals kommentiert hat
so die rudi michel hat das auch eher
nüchtern fest gehalten nachdem diese das
tor nicht gegeben worden ist nach dem
motto oh pro das wird noch diskussionen
geben genau in diesem tonfall und
verspricht hilfe unter die jahrzehnte
darüber aber ich glaube dass die
deutsche mannschaft natürlich sich dort
genauso wie boris becker im bündelten
die hat dort irgendwie ein kleines
monster mehr gefunden im laufe der
fußballgeschichte ja es gab auch eine
fiese ungerechtigkeit muss man sagen für
die engländer nicht im wembley sondern
in südafrika das war bei der wm 2010
aber das gehört auch zu dieser rivalität
dazu denn das war sozusagen wembley
reloaded allerdings diesmal auf der
anderen seite einen schuss von lampard
wenn wir den fläche auch grad nochmal
zeigen wollen
der geht auch an die unterkante tel
hatte und dann aber sowas von eindeutig
hinter die linie
das ist dann schon wirklich eine
ziemlich schreiende ungerechtigkeit war
noch sehe ich die bilder nicht wäre
schön wenn man so gerade noch mal zeigen
könnten aber jetzt habe ich im prinzip
die szene schon geschildert billa es war
wirklich für alle eigentlich zu erkennen
dass der ball weit hinter der linie war
und daran werden sich auch noch der eine
oder andere spieler von heute vielleicht
erinnern und ich glaube du hast selber
auch noch ganz lebhafte erinnerungen an
diesen moment ja das war ein ko spiel es
war nicht im wembley sondern im blut von
t
der schuss kam von frank lampard und es
war eine grandiose sagen wir eingebung
von manuel neuer sofort in bar aus zu
schaufeln und weiterzuspielen und
unschuldig gucken kann da ja mit seinem
großen blauen augen und dann ging das
spiel weiter und alle spieler haben es
gesehen die engländer waren hatte die
völlig außer sich und ich glaube dieses
tor war ein puzzleteil da zumindest ein
entscheidendes das beschlossen worden
ist im video assistenten einzuführen
weil das wäre das wäre das gewesen
hätten die engländer verkürzt auf zwei
zu eins so wäre es gewesen deutschland
führte zwar zu null
da werden die rangekommen und dann finde
ich es dann doch 4 2 2 ausgegangen für
deutschland aber
das ist genauso ein historisches tor im
sinne von weil das verursache ist von
der regel im weltfußball damit den
videobeweis
ja ist ja sagt ja auch tatsächlich muss
man sagen für mehr gerechtigkeit wir
wollen jetzt noch mal versuchen den
beitrag von lars ruthemann zu zeigen wie
gesagt noch mal mit aktuellen bildern
und informationen vor dem spiel england
gegen deutschland
es ist angerichtet im altehrwürdigen
wembley stadion für einen großen
fußballabend die frage welches gesicht
wird das deutsche team diesmal zeigen
dass rundherum erfreulicher aus dem
portugals spiel oder das er miesepetrige
aus der partie gegen ungarn
es ist jetzt für beide mannschaften ein
alles oder nichts spiel also das heißt
es gibt nur einen gewinner und dann
einen verlierer der eben nach hause muss
von daher ist die brisanz natürlich
gegeben
trotz der sich in england rasant
verbreitenden delta variante des corona
virus sind am abend 45.000 zuschauer
zugelassen in der klaren mehrzahl
engländer den fans aus deutschland
dürfen nicht einreisen von sportler klar
ist immer ist immer geil wenn die hütte
mit eigenen fans gefüllt ist aber ja
fast genauso geil ist es wenn das ganze
stadion irgendwie gegnern ist analog zum
englischen team will auch die deutsche
mannschaft mit dem kniefall ein zeichen
gegen rassismus und für toleranz setzen
und englands kapitän harry caine wird
wie manuel neuer die regenbogen binde
tragen
wir ziehen da sofort mit und finden das
gut auch wenn man sich so positioniert
wie die engländer schon seit längerem
auch tun wir haben in der mannschaft
darüber diskutiert die mannschaft hat
darüber diskutiert und hat besprochen
was morgen zu tun ist und sie haben dann
auch uns gesagt dass sie eben auch den
kniefall machen und das ist natürlich
ein tolles zeichen starke gesten die
beide teams schon vor dem anpfiff zu
gewinnern machen
[Applaus]
ja starke gesten darüber hatten wir
gerade gesprochen
zwei gewinner im übertragenen sinne aber
wie gesagt eine mannschaft kommt dann
halt weiter und da gucken wir vielleicht
gerade noch einmal auf den turnier baum
denn man kann schon sagen die mannschaft
die da jetzt weiter kommt das sind die
bilder nochmal vom stadion genau das
sehen was wir säen oben rechts
eingeblendet hier deutschland gegen
england trifft dann im viertelfinale auf
den sieger der partie schweden gegen die
ukraine das dann am main 21 uhr heute
abend also was ich sagen will ist wenn
man dann schaut gegen wen ist weiter
gehen würde dann muss man ja schon sagen
bei alldem los pech dass die deutschen
hatten in der vorrunde mit eben
frankreich und portugal als relativ
starken gegnern das weitere turnier
geschehen halbfinale wäre dann sieger
dänemark gegen tschechien bei allem
respekt sieht eigentlich wähler bis ins
finale gar nicht so schlecht aus wie
wäre deine einschätzung dazu todes größe
mit frankreich portugal und deutschland
nur noch deutschland übrig die franzosen
den raus die portugiesen sind raus und
meine hoffnung besteht doch darin dass
mannschaft denen der in der gruppenphase
nicht so gut gespielt haben plötzlich
aufdrehten im umgekehrten fall zeigt wie
die holländer waren bot in der
gruppenphase der aussieht hat je nach
damit mit großer mühe nur die nächste
runde erreicht also das war schon so
dass viele mannschaften die die wie in
der gruppenphase stark sieht das war
aber diesem turnier so bei anderen auto
so wird sich in der bauphase das latein
kriegen und ich finde es ganz gut dass
das dass joachim lösung im grunde
genommen mit einer fast schon stammelf
ihr durchgeht auch wenn die wechselnde
leistungen gezeigt hat aber die spieler
werden von spiel zu spiel besser
aufeinander abgestimmt sein oder auch
nur gewechselt die mittelfeld weil weil
gündogan an sich leider konkurrenz der
einzige sagte ich mal freiwillige
wechselt vorne ist die moderne
ich stelle mir vor gericht da bin ich
nicht sicher ob das die richtige
maßnahme ist aber der kern der
mannschaft bleibt zusammen und
dann den leichteren weg bekannt wäre
natürlich wenn man weiter kommt und dann
im viertelfinale auf die damals sehr
schwierig zu bespielenden schweden
trifft die die hat also eine ente die
spitzbergen und die alpen und alle
sämtliche defensiven maßnahmen ergreifen
werden die es nur gibt irgendwie das
erste spiel von joachim löw war ja du
wirst gegen schweden 2006 sehr schade
weil sich da der kreis schlösse dass wir
das letzte spiel dann sind wir alle
gespannt wie das weitergeht unser
kollege nils kaben der befindet sich im
stadion und kann uns gerade noch mal mit
ein paar wirklich brand aktuellen
informationen versorgen zu diesem spiel
alle mit denen wir gesprochen haben
heute der immigration officer am
flughafen der taxifahrer die kollegen
hier im stadion zu sagen alle das wird
eine ganz ganz enge kiste
man kann die prognose so zusammenfassen
wer das erste tor schießt gewinnt das
spiel
wer das spiel gewinnt wird europa ist da
das meinen die engländer
es wird auf jeden fall eine eine sehr
magische haben der bisher magische nacht
hier in london
die aufstellung muss kraus drei
änderungen gibt's auf der deutschen
seite werner kommt für cabrio red cafe
verloren das war schon erwartet worden
und müller kehrt für die startelf zurück
und es werden 45.000 menschen hier im
wembley stadion sein und die werden denn
die gleich die nationalhymne singen
für eine ordentliche gänsehaut sorgen
die deutsche mannschaft ist seit sieben
spielen ungeschlagen um hoffen dass die
serie heute nicht reißt ja das wollen
wir hoffen dieses kamen war das vielen
dank wähler vielleicht noch mal deine
letzte einschätzung zum spiel und
vielleicht auch mit einem tipp wie ist
dein gefühl was schätzt du wie geht die
kiste heute aus vielleicht ist die idee
werner zu bringen deshalb geborene
joachim löw weil die engländer durch
spiel machen werden ein wenig da der
raum für seine geschwindigkeit
mein tipp clou das ist jetzt deutschland
england okay wie greift man die
geschichte ich sag mal eins zu eins nach
120 minuten und
england verlässt das turnier durch das
siegtor durch das southgate e-mails
meter schießen war schön formuliert also
da würden wir uns wahrscheinlich gehen
gerne anschließen
deutschland würde demnach weiterkommen
im elfmeterschießen das wäre der
klassiker dann im klassiker vielen dank
wähler für diese einschätzungen
dankeschön und einen schönen abends und
für freude am spiel und wir sprechen
weiter mit andreas stamm in london und
andreas haben ja gerade schon mal kurz
gehört hast ein bisschen was schon
zustimmung gesagt vielleicht noch mal
ganz kurz für diejenigen die sich später
zu gestaltet haben ist das auf der insel
genau so ein klassiker wie in
deutschland wie wird das da gesehen
das ist nicht irgendein klassiker das
ist der klassiker es gibt vier worte die
englische fußball fans elektrisieren wie
nichts anderes turnier
wembley deutschland england da kommt
nichts mehr drüber
und das spürt man hier und dazu kommt
natürlich auch dass man nach langen
monaten der pandemie auf des fußball
entzugs aber auch lebens entzug
so war das hier vier monate die letzten
jahr sommer mal bis april mai war vier
fünf monate london wirklich dicht und
nicht nur london sondern weite teile des
landes und das dass das lässt es nicht
heute richtig nachempfinden die leute
wollen ein schönes fußballfest haben
natürlich unter den bedingungen dass
corona immer noch teil unseres lebens
ist dass die pandemie gerade hier wieder
zurück schlägt wenn man das mal so
formulieren darf und die delta variante
wirklich die infektionszahlen stark nach
oben steigen lässt aber das tut der
stimmung hier und da darf man sich
nichts vormachen keinen abbruch hier
feiern
40.000 englische fans ein ganz großes
fußballfest
ja und das ist doch einigermaßen
erstaunlich finde ich wenn man jetzt
hört dass du hast ja also da wird in
erster linie doch das positive betont
und eben dieser gedanke dass man endlich
wieder fußball spiele vom publikum
feiern kann in diesem sinne wenn man
nach deutschland schaut da sind doch
viele stimmen auch in der öffentlichkeit
zu hören die davor warnen
zum einen da hinzufahren zum anderen
aber auch das ist unverantwortlich
finden gerade auch aus der politik da
solche spiele überhaupt stattfinden vor
45.000 zuschauern ist man da in
england zu unkritisch deiner meinung
nach oder wie ist das zu bewerten
also ich sag mal so es gibt natürlich
hier auch virologen und experten die
sagen das ist wirklich keine gute idee
delta ist so hoch ansteckend und
natürlich social distance in
abstandsregeln all das ich meine zwei
point getrunken ist das über bord da
macht da darf man sich nichts vormachen
hier trägt auch keiner maske auch im
stadion ich war bei zwei england spielen
zuvor da ist keiner mit maske also das
ist einfach eine andere welt und das ist
schwierig aber für die regierung und
auch für die uefa die halten sich da
bedeckt die regierung sagt immer zwei
drittel der erwachsenen in
großbritannien sind mittlerweile
zweifach geimpft das schützt vor der
delta variante und wir vergleichen die
zahlen also wir hatten gestern glaube
ich 22.000 neuinfektionen am tag wenn
man das vergleich mit den zahlen im
dezember das zum letzten mal so war
damals sind 1800 menschen ins
krankenhaus eingeliefert worden am
selben tag das sind heute nur in
anführungszeichen 200 und auch ist
sterben im moment kaum menschen ist
sterben menschen aber eben kaum viel
weniger als in anderen bällen zu
vergleichbaren zeitpunkten und das sagt
die britische regierung nun das ist der
impfschutz den wir erreicht haben
deswegen wir können wieder mehr leben
und wir sollten es auch in gewisser
weise und das ist sozusagen die
argumentation einige sehen das sehr viel
kritischer und gerade weil hier auch
viele jüngere und weniger gut gedämpfte
aufeinandertreffen aber das ist die lage
und hier wirklich keiner das fußball
fest verderben lassen
ja irgendwo ja auch verständlich und
football's coming home wie wir jetzt
gerade hören gabi lücke auf facebook
schreibt uns wichtiger ist dass alle
gesund zurückkommen also hier gibt es
offenbar mehr um die gesundheit als um
das ergebnis auf das er irgendwo
verständlich und marita werke schreibt
unverantwortlich das spiel keiner hält
sich an die regeln naja gut und das ist
eben die eine sichtweise die du ja
gerade auch schon ein bisschen bestätigt
hast welche maßnahmen andreas werden
denn ergriffen vor ort müssen die leute
die jetzt kommen müssen die allen test
gemacht haben müssen sie alle zweifach
geimpft sein wie muss man sich das
vorstellen
also um entscheidungen rein zu kommen
braucht man entweder den nachweis dass
man zweimal geimpft ist oder man muss
seinen negativen test vorweisen
allerdings sind das schnelltests und die
kammern am abend oder am tag selbst
durchführen und man bestätigt dann
sozusagen registriert dann und
versichert dass dieser test negativ war
diese tests sind wie wir wissen nicht
hundertprozentig das heißt es gibt da
ein sehr grobmaschiges raster natürlich
gilt eigentlich masken pflicht im
stadion auch abstandsregeln aber
wirklich da muss man jetzt kein
hellseher sein das hat in den spielen
zuvor nicht wirklich gut funktioniert
und das wird auch heute nicht gut
funktionieren auch weil die
zuschauerzahlen noch mal verdoppelt
wurde und für die für das finale und die
beiden halbfinals die hier in wembley
stattfinden sollen ja noch mal mehr
zuschauer rein also das ist schon sagen
wir mal einen ritt auf der rasierklinge
wenn man das von corona pandemie seite
aussieht aber es ist eben die realität
hier und wie gesagt in großbritannien in
england wird das nicht wirklich so
thematisiert wie in deutschland wo die
diskussion spitzenpolitiker
gesundheitsexperten also die habe ich
hier nicht gehört und nicht gesehen ja
also bei uns im forum sind die leute
jedenfalls kritisch lkv schreibt es ist
erschreckend welche gesundheitlichen
risiken die leute für fußball auf sich
nehmen da wäre jetzt noch mal meine
frage wie viele deutsche werden denn
jetzt eigentlich konkret erwartet es war
immer nur von wenigen tausend die rede
kannst du das bestätigen
ja das war ja klar
selbst wenn deutsche fans nach
großbritannien hätten kommen wollen und
mit einem ticket ist das ja
grundsätzlich möglich aber wenn sie
freitags morgens nach dem fest stand
dass deutschland gegen england hier
aufläuft in den flieger gestiegen werden
werden sie jetzt immer noch in
quarantäne denn man muss ja mindestens
fünf tage in quarantäne kann sich dann
frei testen und das ist überhaupt nicht
möglich das heißt die deutschen fans die
hier sind 2000 karten wurden an deutsche
fans verkauft das sind deutsche die
nachweislich eine einen wohnsitz in
großbritannien haben und die
denen ist es erlaubt die herzukommen ist
natürlich ein bisschen leichtes
missverhältnis 40.000 engländer 2000
deutsche fans deutsche fans von der
insel aber das ist die realität und
reisen hierher fans ausnahmen das hatte
man diskutiert die uefa so heißt es hat
wohl mit der britischen regierung auch
darüber geredet ob man fans aus
verschiedenen nationen nicht auch
ausnahmeregeln zukommen lassen könnte
wie vielen funktionären offiziellen und
vips aber das glaube ich wäre des guten
dann doch sehr sehr sehr viel zu viel
gewesen sind die engländer denn
eigentlich sportlich gesehen
optimistisch also ich meine die haben
die leistung der deutschen gesehen sie
haben ihre eigenen gesehen wie
zuversichtlich sind sie dass sie
weiterkommen also die deutsche
mannschaft hat den eindruck erweckt hier
dass sie schlagbar ist und so sehen es
auch die buchmacher zum beispiel da sind
die engländer hauchdünner favorit
natürlich ist dieser last der geschichte
gilt die idee ist auf den englischen
schultern also kein gegner ja wird hier
so gefürchtet wie die deutschen eben bis
auf das eine mal haben es ja eben mit
béla réthy besprochen und er hat dass er
auch geklärt ist ob das eine mal in
wembley ging es eigentlich immer schief
und diese last die ist natürlich ist
natürlich zu spüren als insofern sind
die engländer verhalten optimistisch im
inneren glaube glaube ich sind viele so
die deutschen werden schon wieder packen
aber wenn wir es schaffen dann machen
wir die elf die auf dem platz steht zu
fußball helden und zur wahrheit gehört
auch dazu also 1996 als es das letzte
aufeinandertreffen beim großen turnier
gab da waren viele im aktuellen kader
der erinnern da noch gar nicht geboren
also vielleicht machen sie sich deswegen
auch nicht allzu viel kopf- und das wäre
ja wahrscheinlich ihnen auch anzuraten
andreas zum schluss auch noch mal
vielleicht deine einschätzung zum spiel
dein tipp was glaubst du wie geht es aus
béla réthy hat man jetzt den bisschen
versaut der noch elfmeterschießen hatte
ich auch gesetzt einfach schon aus
historischen gründen
aber ganz ehrlich ich hab so ein
bisschen die sorge dass die deutsche
defensive ich bin nicht der allergrößte
fußball expertin bei weitem nicht die
béla réthy aber was ich da gesehen hat
man große große löcher und wie sie die
stopfen wollen gegen eine relativ
kompakt stehende zumindest hinten
stehende englische mannschaft
ich bin skeptisch also ich fürchte das
könnte heute ins auge gehen für die
deutsche nationalmannschaft was
natürlich einer afghanistan den effekt
dass hier auf dieser fanmeile heute
abend noch eine ganz ganz große party
steigt oder pandemien oder hin
andreas vielen dank für diese
einschätzung für deinen tipp und auch
für die stimmungsvollen bilder vom ort
des geschehens nachher vom model stadion
dankeschön andreas nach london und
angeblich auch noch schnell ein tipp ab
ich sagt die deutschen schaffens in der
regulären spielzeit 21 würde ich jetzt
einfach mal raus haben noch um zwei
stimmen zum schluss vielleicht keilholz
hofer schreibt uns über facebook gut
dass keine deutschen fenster england
durften beziehungsweise halt eben nur
wenige die halt dort leben und carola
beschreibt leiden das ist
unverantwortlich trotzdem möge der
bessere gewinnen und das ist natürlich
immer richtig dem können wir uns
anschließen wir hoffen vor allem dass es
ein gutes spiel wird das ist verbleibt
und das ist ja am ende
naja gut kann man sagen vielleicht doch
ganz gut für die deutschen skeet ich
danke euch und ihnen fürs zuschauen und
wir sagen einen schönen abend und bis
zum nächsten mal viel spaß heute abend
beim fußball toto